you know some things in breath of the
wild man and in mad no not in the oh my
gosh I'm just so angry kind of way but
in the what the heck why would you put
that there kind of way
kind of like the ruins of Lon Lon ranch
you know this ranch right here you see
how it's called the ranch ruins you see
how it's exactly the same layout of Lon
Lon ranch from ocarina of time complete
even down to the door in that milk
storehouse behind the ranch
yeah it's obviously Lon Lon ranch but
how could simple wooden structures and
fences that are completely exposed to
the elements survived more than ten
thousand plus years that have passed
since the events of Ocarina of Time took
place you see we're mad it just doesn't
make logical sense while it's still such
an obvious reference maybe I'm taking
things just a little too seriously I
mean I am a theorist but hmm either way
it seems like Nintendo sometimes just
decided to put stuff around this world
of Hyrule and then let the fans piece
together what they mean or what they
were references to in fact I know that's
what they were thinking because that was
essentially their answer for its time
line placement but anyway another one of
these places that's just kind of there
and doesn't have any official
explanation for its existence is the
ancient tree stump that's right the
giant tree surrounded by a little lake
with the back hablen camp on top and the
lizalfos having a nice fun day in the
water below you've all seen it we've all
seen it but nobody knows what the actual
heck it's supposed to be but you know I
wouldn't be a theorist if this sort of
thing didn't bother me and trust me it
does so I started to really take in the
surroundings and wouldn't you know it
there are some very very peculiar things
this whole area has got going on so much
so that I think I have the giant sliced
woods backstory figured out so without
further ado let's delve into what
happened to the ancient tree stump in
breadth of the wild
so first off let's take a look at the
stump itself and deduce what we can
about its current state of decapitation
not only is it you know a stump but it
has a makeshift log bridge connecting
nearby land to its surface its severed
upper portion appears to have been
cleanly cut off for the most part except
for some of the outer bark sticking up
in certain places meaning whatever cut
this ancient tree down to stumps eyes
did so intentionally or with great care
in fact it has what appears to be other
branches that have also been cleanly cut
off as well
no splintering at all strange indeed
other than its stump state and the fact
that it's giant and really really old
there isn't much more we can gather from
the stump itself except for one really
odd detail that ultimately isn't that
important but I can't help to point out
because it is so odd that leaves okay
let me back up and explain this real
quick you see the stump appears to be at
least in part still alive there are
little branches that have recently been
sprouting on the sides of the tree
meaning the stump is actually alive and
growing new branches that we can see in
game this sort of thing actually does
happen to stumps in real life and some
of you watching who are more
knowledgeable than I am with trees and
such can probably back me up on this but
when a tree stump actually keeps on
living and growing branches and whatnot
it's called a living stump without
trying to explain too much detail about
the science behind living stumps and you
know probably making a fool of myself it
has to do with the outer layer of the
stump living on while the center of it
is dead this may even explain the fact
that the stump seems to have been
cleanly sawed through but the outer bark
has overgrown the edges in some places
now back to the leaves this living stump
is producing leaves that are falling and
being scattered around to the water
below and what's especially odd about
this is the fact that these leaves are
different than all the trees surrounding
the lake Nintendo was very peculiar in
detailing these skinny trees complete
with their needle-like leaves showering
the ground and even the water beneath
them but then they detailed the
distinctly morass
looking leaves that the stump produces
in the middle which according to their
color look like they've only fallen
there recently and seeing as the wind
looks like it's normally blowing at
least slightly to the east this tree
sitting way out here would be the only
other possibility of providing leaves of
this shape to the lake but what are the
chances that the wind takes leaves from
this tree and puts them all the way over
there in the middle of the lake and in
that quantity so ok I've detailed the
stump and the leaves itself but let's
move on to its surroundings aside from
the different species of trees that
surround the stump the next glaringly
obvious feature to point out would be
the destroyed buildings that are present
at the edge of the lake near the start
of the bridge and under the water
immediately surrounding the stumps roots
this means there used to be some sort of
civilization here next to the tree
probably because of the tree the
buildings as far as I can tell were of
highly and build and design comparing
them to the various other buildings that
are similarly destroyed around Hyrule
but something struck me as particularly
odd about the building's locations so
there are some underwater right I mean
we can see them right there I'm assuming
they weren't built under the water
meaning this area used to not be a lake
but looking at the bowl like crater that
the tree is rooted in who would build
structures in an area like this that's
so easily flooded I mean it's almost a
perfect bowl given how intensely prone
to raining this area of Hyrule is
wouldn't this kind of flooding happen
like every other day as in often enough
to flood while whoever built these
houses was busy building the said houses
so it hit me there must have been some
sort of drainage for all this water back
in the day otherwise why and how would
these buildings have been built here
looking around there really doesn't seem
to be any possible way to drain the
water from this lake the only escape the
water would have from sitting stagnant
lee in this lake would be either
evaporation or absorption into the
ground below both of which don't happen
nearly fast enough to save buildings
from drowning in a flood I mean it
really is quite the perfect little
crater but then I saw it all along the
craters edge you can see the colour of
the exposed dirt and sand right
pretty uniform in color and texture
except for the side facing the eastern
fields you see there's some pretty light
colored sand here where it isn't present
anywhere else in the lake that mixes
with a texture the game uses for rubble
that kind of drops off immediately after
touching the water and for literally
anyone who has seen any part of this
game ever this sand should be pretty
familiar looking to you it's the same
color of all the sand present all over
the great plateau it's the same sand
present all over the ruins of Hylian
fortresses you see on bones yet it's
construction sand it's used wherever
hylians have built forts houses temples
are even foundations of castle towns
they used the sand to level surfaces for
construction and it's present here on
this side of this lake that at one point
must have been able to drain the water
from its basin otherwise these buildings
would not have been built in this
location the sand is visible in various
parts of Hyrule due to all the ruins
present and the damage that occurred in
the calamity 100 years ago and with one
of these walls of this crater being
seemingly made of construction sand and
this rubble texture I think there used
to be some sort of large Hylian
structure built here that has since been
completely destroyed and collapsed so
with all of these clues the living stump
the submerged buildings the surrounding
trees and the artificial hill made of
rubble and construction sand
let's piece together what may have
happened to the ancient tree more than
100 years ago I believe the tree was
huge that much is apparent but it was so
huge that the hylians in there let's
call it desire for conquest and need to
expand saw the tree as a huge
opportunity for an enormous amount of
wood for the harvesting I mean after all
when you need a natural resource like
wood discovering a singular giant
healthy tree with enough wood to build
an entire civilization out of is like
sweet ocarina music - a lumberjack's
ears so with the harvesting of the giant
tree in mind naturally that would take a
long time in lots of hands over lots of
hours of work to accomplish right I mean
how would you even start harvesting a
giant tree do you just chop it down and
let the entire massive column crashing
to the earth or do you start from the
top and slice it in pieces working down
the tree piece by piece
I think that's what they did and at the
base of the large tree they built
buildings for the workers that labored
at this wood factory I think they had
all sorts of buildings from dorms for
the workers to a large complex wood
processing plant directly to the east of
the tree they continued on with this
harvesting for however long it took to
get to this height branch by branch and
slice by slice until one day the
calamity struck ganon and his minions
laid waste to the land of Hyrule by and
large destroying every building and
every home they laid their eyes on even
remote civilizations like the shadow
hamlet ruins were not safe in their
violence the Hylian constructions around
the wood factory were completely
destroyed and the foundations of their
buildings where the construction sand
was present caved and created a wall
completing the crater surrounding the
tree over the following 100 years the
rains flooded the lake with water
permanently submerging the old buildings
under the surface but also providing
water for grass and trees to grow on the
edges of the crater natural irony and
that is my theory on what happened to
the ancient tree stump let me know what
you thought in the comments below also
real quick before I end I wanted to
touch on just a couple quick pointers
that are probably still on everybody's
minds first up touching on the log
bridge connecting to the surface of the
tree stump seeing as it's you know
pretty decently intact and made of some
pretty skinny looking logs it was
probably built sometime within the past
hundred years by the blue Copland's and
mod ones that have been patrolling the
area they just saw a cool spot for a
camp and decided to build a bridge to
get there I mean they are known for
crafting very unique camps and whatnot
but of course they're all so disgusting
which is why there's a bunch of trash on
top of the tree and the skinny logs that
they used to make the bridge out of
we're probably just taken from these
skinny trees lying around everywhere
also really quick I wanted to mention
that while I didn't touch on what this
tree used to be at home as in whether or
not I believe this is an old dica tree I
do have some guesses if you guys want me
to touch on that in a future video let
me know down below and I'll keep it in
mind as always huge thank you to all of
you for watching leave a like for this
video if you enjoyed it and make sure
you're subscribed with that Bell icon so
you don't miss out on
anymore Nintendo goodness and to my
amazing patrons who make my day every
day I have three new editions say hello
to the epic Robert roar back of dusty
day and Lou Silverman who have joined my
elite crew if you're interested in
getting your name up here at the end of
each of my videos feel free to check out
the link in the description below also
down there are the links to my social
media pages so come on over and say hi
this is mass antena Banat signing out
wash your hands and stay safe people
[Music]